when before I began this interview
steven crowder was in fact wearing pants
he walked into the room not wearing
pants to make me specifically
uncomfortable more we do sell them since
you haven't plugged my stuff you've been
plugging psychologists at the lot of
credit merchants or calm so here we are
on the Sunday special with steven
crowder who lacks pants and we will get
to all of the questions for steven
crowder we will ask him why indeed he
feels that it is necessary and
appropriate for him not to wear pants
and thus to show his junk to the entire
world but first let's talk a little bit
about talk space the online therapy
company that lets you message a licensed
therapist from anywhere at any time
look steven crowder could use a
therapist and you might need to as well
all you need is a computer with internet
connection or the talks based mobile app
that means you can improve your mental
health even if you had trouble making
time for it in the past there's no
stigma attached you know I am a big
advocate of if you got something on your
chest and you need to get it off your
chest you should talk to somebody who
knows what they are talking about and
that's why you should be talking about
everyday challenges at work or at home
you can chat about life there no extra
commutes no leaving the office no
judgement remember therapy isn't just
about venting those thoughts are digging
into childhood memories it's about
practical everyday strategies for stress
management and living a happier life
having a therapist simply provides you a
designated person for you to talk to
who's trained to listen and help you
make positive changes the talk space
platform has over 2,000 licensed
therapists who are experienced in
addressing life challenges we all face
to match the perfect therapist for a
fraction the price the price of
traditional therapy go to talk space.com
slash Schapiro use that promo code
Shapiro at 45 bucks off your first month
show your support for the show
that's Shapiro talk space.com slash
Shapiro and again 45 bucks off your
first month I'm big advocate as I say of
if you need help talk to somebody and
talk space can make it happen for you at
a fraction of the price to going to a
therapist is totally worth it go check
it out right now talk space.com slash
Shapiro alright steven crowder this is
gonna be hard for me how many of those
are we gonna have to do what I do four
of those I'm so tempted to screw all of
them up for you I know and you already
had one so congratulations you did you
did you did stumble a little bit I know
well you know you actually ducking into
my camera line and then pouring water
into your own mug is always definitely a
wonderful no no I just don't trust you
look back at you dude I mean I'm the one
wearing pants so all I can say is that
when before we began this interview
steven crowder was in fact wearing pants
he walked into the room now
wearing pants to make me specifically
uncomfortable because as most people
know I am deeply uncomfortable with the
male body well I think you're deeply
uncomfortable with the men and women of
our armed services because this is what
they wear they were ranger panties or
they're known softies in the Navy so I
don't know why I don't know why you
would disrespect them that way our more
we didn't tell them since you haven't
plugged my stuff you've been plugging
psychologists at a lot of credit merch
store comm and of course everyone knows
for the Mudd Club of it yeah if I were
more of a patriot I'd be staring at your
junk with with more enthusiasm but
apparently I am not so all right let's
jump into it let's jump into what you do
for a living which is supposedly comedy
allegedly so yes it's so steven crowder
for those who know for a guy who's so
smart that was redundant right off the
supposedly allegedly let's try and curb
back the flaw supposedly it says
supposedly is not a legal term allegedly
is but let's talk a little bit about how
you got to where you are so he runs a
show a lawyer present
I mean a half age and Pilbara schmancer
always I'm Jewish but you know the
Crowder is sitting here and and people
should know the way that I got to know
steven crowder was in fact as his lawyer
so many many years ago we got to know
each other because I was recommended to
Steven for some odd reason as somebody
who might be able to negotiate a
contract I think it was Andrew Breitbart
well it was probably Andrew it's always
Andrew which made no sense because it
wasn't the kind of law that you did
right but I can read a contract yeah and
so anyone Jewish this is correct any
trust at you and I remember that you
went in and you weep Connery bad
qualities right off the bat employer
who's Jewish no no I said I don't know
trusted me someone who could do this and
I remember he said this guy you know I
trust this this guy he's younger but
he'll know how to take care of you
ever we went in kinda like the Donald
Trump we try to negotiate going in hi
mm-hmm and we'd expect them to come back
but they didn't right there we just know
and I'm err I thought you were probably
probably held some animosity toward me
because you were like crap I should have
come in lower because you know I was
making so much more than you it's true
you you are you were really earning at
that point and then the first time that
the first time that we met in person
steven crowder came to my came to my
condo
yeah i can't remember why you were there
at all I mean just so he heard this
giant Canadian and he and were upstairs
and I'm about to do a radio show or
something yeah and you decided to
demonstrate your Brazilian Jujitsu
skills by putting me in a headlock and
then there's a guillotine choke but you
said you had a hernia only after I put
you in the choke that's true I was like
why don't you tell me before this and
then I then I felt bad but only a little
bit
right but I didn't launch a lawsuit
against you in that was the beginning of
our French yes it was the beginning of
our friendship the same thing he did my
Fox News contract early on because yeah
you know listen at that point I wasn't
really obviously I wasn't looking for
anything special but I remember I just
said I know some people don't own the
rights to their own names and I want to
be protected I want to make sure that I
maintain kind of my autonomy and you did
you you helped to help me with that at
that point that we enable I don't have a
lot of negotiating power yeah but it was
it was very helpful no it's always good
that my legal skill was talked up the
beginning of a show so I appreciate that
well Stephen is indeed the creator and
the host of louder with Crowder which is
the most successful comedy comedy show
on the right I think pretty clearly and
obviously I mean he has a second-rate
mug which we've allowed him to actually
bring in here pour his water into
obviously this right here the left is
tears hot or cold tumblr is far superior
to Apollo it has more bulk now sort of
the reverse of our bots it employs a lot
of Chinese children this is short and
fat like me and this one's tall and
skinny like you but in any case the the
the the show is is takes a lot of work
it's really worth watching so I wanted
to ask
let's get deep into the weeds with
steven crowder from the very beginning
how did you go from a misanthropic
canadian child to a giant texan comedian
in one short life you know it's it's I
was always it's the only thing I ever
wanted to do did you ever want to do
anything else as a kid did you ever want
to be a fireman or a policeman I mean I
know your plan when I was interested in
in like genetic science I was also a
violinist so I thought about than that
okay I was always very nice all the
Asian is doing the violin you were like
I was pretty violinist
I know you were very good violinist but
you know different to be honest with you
it wasn't really about the race I don't
think your parents were jamming piano
keys into your neck if you missed a mr.
note I have a lawyer right now happy
actually his mommy's to slam the piano
on his fingers talk about tech like he
talks about it hits Tiger mom and he's
brilliant at he's nice so he's an SMU
law grad that's actually you know that's
a funny story speaking of Texas so my
half-asian lawyer bill rich from an SMU
law grad when we did the show at SMU he
was in there he was a part of the show
he was in the crowd and we did a parody
of say anything where he was holding up
a boombox and in your eyes but Peter
Gabriel was playing but he's walking in
and there are these protestors and the
other side of the street it was like
there was a poultry like 40 people but
one of them was his law professor he
goes bill what do you say I'm in the
show I'm protesting the show so I kind
of assumed that in law you would have
more conservative professors turns out I
guess that's
okay certainly not anymore yeah and
maybe major law firms are very very much
the left animal at one point I'll have
to do a show where I talk about all my
experiences in my interviews for for
being a lawyer like I was at Harvard Law
School and I was interviewed by 32 firms
the way works at Harvard is that
everybody shows up to recruit you
because you're at Harvard Law School
which means you're smart and so they
then come to the they come to the
Charles hotel but that was the self pat
for sponsors I don't see how creative he
is with the compliments that was a
selfie yeah no it means you're smart
it's smooth I tell you what's not smart
is these generic chairs my back is gonna
be strong I have to get up and stretch
right in front of you well please do not
and in any case 32 school 32 different
firms came and recruited me and I went 1
for 32 on my interview specifically
because I was right-wing and they saw in
my resume that aydin's my books but in
any case let's get back to you I want to
I want to compliment you there because a
lot this is one thing I know that
bothers you and bothers me a lot people
say all was because it was right-wing no
in this case it's true because anyone
out there who knows your background in
law and listen I you know I I despise
you of course all that but you are
supremely qualified and it's clear that
there was a bias against your political
world I mean they pretty much said it
yeah I know you could bother when people
say well I didn't get accepted right
because I was that was at Schenectady
Community College and I bombed out so
well no ha it's not because you were
conservative it's the same thing with a
lot of sort of conservative self
professed comedians sometimes like I
know every single conservative in the
comedy any industry entertainment is
very certainly comedy and a lot of
people just say well it's because I was
right-wing so well ha I guess because
you're not there yet I don't need to say
they're not good they're not there yet
so in that case I want people to know
that is entirely legitimate that it was
because of your worldview and probably
because you couldn't keep your mouth
shut about it well so on my resume the
the name of my second book was porn
generation how social liberalism is
corrupting our future in one particular
interview with Gibson Dunn and Crutcher
the partner who was interviewing people
I walked in before I even sat down or
said my name he said I walked in the
door I remember this clear as day and he
says it has always been my contention
that conservatives and religious people
in general have a freudian fear of sex
can't even shook my hand yet and at that
point it's like I'm not getting this job
so go you know eff this guy and that was
pretty much I mean ER we would also be
improper verbage because wasn't Freud
the guy who wanted to sleep with his mom
he didn't have a fear of sex he thought
that other people so I guess you're
saying a Freudian complex yes I'm afraid
of that that's what he was going for
yeah in any case let's get back to the
dark in that you completely avoided here
what
was how did you go from being a giant
Canadian to a giant Texan and also did
you always want to do political comedy
or do pure comedy no I always just
wanted to if you'd have asked me when I
was 12 or 13 I would have said I want to
be an Academy award-winning actor really
that's what that truly would have been
my dream I just wanted to act but I also
always loved comedy I started writing
stand-up when I was 14 to do actually
the school talent show which ended up
being cancelled so I just continued
writing so the first time I did stand-up
I think I was 17 but I had to cut down
from about an hour of material to five
minutes
most people bomb their first time the
only reason I didn't bomb was because I
had so much material to edit back but
don't ever know how corrupt obviously
the academy is and that the awards
didn't mean a whole lot I said okay what
I want what do I want to do I was just
talking about this with Dennis Prager
not long ago I said okay if I can't be
an Academy award-winning actor
late-night host so it's like you know my
my Safety's Harvard and at that point
you know I don't know who your who's
your favorite late-night host of all
well time aside from yours truly hobbies
not all time I wasn't Leno fan really
yes ah I know ah breakin my heart see I
was I was all about Letterman until
later on when he came a grumpy man but
early Letterman like the Larry bud
Melman okay Rupert's deli that was real
and more sophisticated yes in comedy yes
I know
okay that's the comedians want to do
Leno because of the numbers and it was
an easy interview but the comedians all
respected Dave that was kind of the rule
until again later on he's totally
changed so early Letterman and I used to
watch it every day my dad would tape it
and put it on VHS and of course
fast-forward the parts that we couldn't
watch and I always just thought wow this
is something really cool that I'd love
to be a part of and I did stand-up for a
long time I always think I wanted to
entertain people and when I saw people
like Nick DiPaolo do stand-up you know
I'd get Conor I'd feel bad about myself
because I would say I'm never going to
be as good as Nick DiPaolo I'm a good
stand-up comedian but a lot of the
things I wanted to do like impressions
sketches didn't work on stage and of
course acting I couldn't do Stan it
couldn't incorporate a lot of comedy not
writers don't typically like you
ad-libbing if people don't know out
there so this really what I'm doing now
is what I've always wanted to do we can
incorporate all of it this is what I've
always wanted to do and it's not really
a right-leaning show but it's really a
late-night show where conservatives
don't need a fear being sucker-punched
you know you have a bit of a harder job
than I did to be honest with you because
I get to be a political pundit who's
occasionally funny but when you're in
the comedic space when people
affect you to be funny all the time yeah
and your hit rate had better be really
incredibly high do you feel a lot of
pressure you having to be funny yeah I
do and I think you know and I feel a lot
of pressure not because it's like oh I
better be funny or it'll it'll hurt my
ego you know when you know this when you
do these live shows I'm not a guy come
up and give me his Navy Cross yeah and
he said I had such bad PTSD and I was
suicidal
he said watching your show is what kept
me saying because I was able to sort of
consume the news I was able to digest it
but I didn't want to kill myself you
know we want we don't want to be the
only show people watch we do more
sourcing I think than anyone honestly we
have we have a rule we have to have two
completely unbiased sources for every
claim that we make we put them on air
you or a leftist source so as a matter
of fact sometimes we'll actually have a
source from Daily wire not like we can't
used it we can use daily wire maybe
we'll say daily wires bullcrap so we go
to the PubMed study which you guys just
saw back you know obviously we're
summarizing but unfortunately people say
it's not legitimate because you know
your shekels and all that so yeah so I
feel a tremendous responsibility if
people are choosing law it was credited
to be their last show before their head
hits the pillow I have always said this
to people who work for me I go listen
they don't know the last show assume
that everyone walking in is walking in
for the first time and they've never
seen your prior performances and earn it
earn their dollar earn their laugh every
single time that's how I tried to
approach it and it really comes the
pressure comes from more of a sense of
responsibility in realizing how much
this means to to other people which
that's something I wasn't ready for
honestly just doing when I was just
doing stand-up and smoker clubs were
drunks were mad at you were doing open
mics you didn't expect someone would
come up and say hey I didn't kill myself
because of your show and I this is
something I know you've you've touched
and I think we've sort of stuck a chord
in in culture right now we hear people
are other all the time there is no group
out there right now who have been other
done anyone under the age of 35 whose
right-leaning
for a long time they feel really
isolated they feel really alone and so
obviously our show is a comedy show and
yours is more like you said sort of
political punditry is that the reality
fairy commentary brilliant commentary uh
it really does make people feel less
alone and it means a lot to them so
that's what the pressure comes from well
let's talk a little bit of what your
routine I'm gonna move these books
because my mug is too dirty and so it's
Wow running into them but yeah let's
talk a little bit about your sort of
routine getting ready for the show
because I have my routine I get ready
for it for you know because I'm in the
news cycle all day long it doesn't take
me that long to actually prep for the
show
because I'm in the news cycle I know
what all the news stories are I know
what all the clips are gonna be but for
you you do that you do the once a week
three-hour show which is the big
extravaganza it's a 1 hour and 15
minutes yeah all three hours wouldn't
used to be on radio but it's a little
longer than the daily show okay so how
often is the daily show is behind the
paywall over at CR TV it's about a 44
minute clock like traditional shows and
then on on Thursday we do one extra game
right and but the amount of it the
amount of time that you put into these
shows is just extraordinary so what is
the organization like for these shows so
well to give you an idea you know I'm up
4:30 or 5:00 and I'm working by 5:30
writing the jokes right in the pitches
because if I write 20 jokes maybe two
will work and we have a couple that
people know who help with some - Owen
Benjamin comes in hourly and it's really
helpful but really for the first for the
first well three years we did it on
Radio and then The Daily Show was just
me and now Brautigan helps a lot he's a
brilliant joke writer who writes for the
website and then we go when we do the
pitch meeting so I'll put in a bunch of
material before the actual pitch meeting
occurs which will occurred around 8:30
in the morning they go in add some of
their ideas or see how they're going to
delegate the tasks because will
typically have like two sketches three
or four photoshop's as far as original
comedy bits and then some punchlines and
then we do a dive in segments or meets
every one is a different term for it
nowadays where we're kind of staking out
one topic that's what usually goes to
YouTube that's the clip people see who
aren't mug Club members and with that
that's where you okay for we have it we
have a beginning middle and end in a
self encapsulated segment that people
can digest and whether it's taking on
the top five ar-15 myths you know of
that day or it's taking on doing a
rebuttal to whoever Vox or Young Turks
we have to be really really meticulous
about our research because we're
actually held to a higher standard funny
enough is comedians because I think the
Jon Stewart comedian hat on journalist
hat off you know actually kind of gave
us less leeway on the right even though
they give it to everyone on the left
though Michelle wolf show got canceled
right here but that I did oh my gosh who
decided that was a good idea who did it
I have no idea Michelle Wolf's immediate
relatives apparently because that thing
was just an abomination so I want to ask
you in a second about you know the
relationship between comedy and madness
but first let's talk about your
impending death so September is national
life insurance Awareness Month
if you listen to this show a lot you've
heard me talk about how important life
insurance is here's the thing 40% of
Americans still do not have life
insurance so
if anything were to happen to you your
family would be left perette that I have
to pay for your coffin but they're poor
because you were too stupid to get life
insurance these days there's not an
excuse for not having life insurance
life insurance rates are at a 20-year
low and it is easier than ever to get
life insurance especially if you use
policy genius policy genius is the easy
way to get life insurance online in just
two minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers to find the best policy
for you and when you compare those
quotes you save money it is indeed that
simple policy genius has helped over 4
million people shop for insurance placed
over 20 billion dollars in coverage they
don't just make life insurance easy they
also compare disability insurance and
renter's insurance and health insurance
as well if you care about it they can
cover it so if you're looking for a good
reason to buy life insurance there are 3
its life insurance awareness month it
rates are 220 or low and policy genius
makes it really easy for you to get that
right policy for you go to policy genius
com get those quotes apply in minutes I
know that Stephens wife has already
taken out a life insurance policy on his
life worth at least $25 so that makes
his life really I mean every minute is
just a fragile balance but you can do
the whole thing for yourself right now
over a policy genius it's the easy way
to compare and buy life insurance I've
been meaning to do this the whole time
you're doing that ad and I didn't want
to screw it up for you so ok recall that
these space heaters made to look like
lights I have no idea it's very bizarre
thing I design my own set the decorative
choices that we make sometimes work for
me dude I think I do this but it is
think about this about the choices like
you've seen like the wooden pallets a
lot of time mm-hmm like oh it seems
really it just seems very organic like
who has a space with these simply
sometimes I said that I'm going like
these are cool what we really do is if
we have a guess we really don't like
them we after the show we strap them
down we shine it really bright in their
face yes and then we just beat them are
those incandescent or the LEDs to look
like an goodness I hadn't I don't know I
don't know I actually like those bulbs
but I do have an insurance question for
you after the show no joke I like
actually send me because as celebrities
now it's a whole different it's a whole
different ballgame oh yeah I had
especially because you get death threats
yeah the rest of exactly it's something
very difficult I want it so let's talk
about the death threats and all that you
actually is a good transition so let's
talk about the the fact that you do a
lot of really controversial comedy so
where do you draw line so you know
there's a lot of talk these days about
where comedians ought to draw lines as
you mention Owen Benjamin owned Benjamin
has been taken to task for using the
n-word in one of his comedy routines
yeah well where do you think it's
appropriate to draw lines of comedians
you think there should be any lines as a
comedian obviously there are certain
things that you want to
even though you're the guy who paints
Muhammad with menstrual blood as Bob
Ross yes on camera where do you decide
where those lines are and when is it
appropriate to cross them okay that's a
good example because context is more
important than content let me let me let
me preface this with I I don't know it
was Phyllis Diller who said this for
hose it might have been Dennis Miller
who repeated it I don't know the
original person who tuned this quote is
attributed but basically nothing is
off-limits except the helpless so in
other words you don't go down to a you
know special needs baby and ha unless
you're a liberal and you want to abort a
Down syndrome baby apparently they're
okay with that so nothing is really
off-limits now I have limitations as to
what I'm comfortable doing and everyone
will have their own line as a society
I'm very uncomfortable with saying this
is these are the list of appropriate
words these are lists of inappropriate
words like we were just talking about
before honor DMX you know I was
listening to his with the n-word mf'er
b-word talking about killing people and
the do we have to bleep me because well
we can believe it okay is the word they
bleep out it's the explicit version
that's the one word they eliminate now
going really these are the words that
we're picking now and of course n-word
would be included if he weren't black so
it really is a political tool and I
never want to play a role in that game
that being said you know I think that's
a good example so you talk about
painting Mohammed and menstrual blood
let's take the context of that that on
its surface sounds bad granted right it
sounds pretty bad but BuzzFeed's boldly
the the land well women they're you know
the fat pride feminists they were
painting and menstrual blood and they
had done a lot of you know of course
always anti Krish anti sort of
judeo-christian videos for a long time
so we did a parody Bob Ross painting
Muhammad and menstrual blood and it got
worse when the Bob Ross estate
threatened to sue us and then we drew
them eating from a pile of a fecal
matter
next to Mohammed I think we never heard
from them again we never seem to get
what I've always said
we're not necessarily a shark in the
comment role but we can be a pufferfish
we'll make them wish they picked
somebody else even if we get torn off of
every platform we'll make them wish that
they picked somebody else that's kind of
our motto so con contextually when you
look at that you go oh this is satire
this is parody we didn't just do it out
of the blue it was featured on YouTube
the women painting with menstrual blood
we didn't start it we didn't we didn't
start a trend to knew it was them so
well they painted first blood not me
what would he make of the
of the merger of sort of comedy and
politics so you're a comedian you label
yourself a comedian everybody knows you
as a comedian but you do see political
actors president from is basically a
stand-up comic most of what he does is
political comedy disguised as politics
and what this means is that he crosses
lines that you will cross but people are
not sure what to make of it are we
supposed to take it like comedy or are
we supposed to take it like politics is
he just being politically incorrect as a
comedian or is he just being a jackass I
think he's thoughtless I think there's a
big difference I mean there's there's no
question that I know where the line is
and I know how to walk up to it and
dance on the line and pull it back you
know if I cross the line it's very
deliberate I don't think that's the case
with President Donald Trump I genuinely
don't think he knows but one thing that
I do think is interesting about Donald
Trump because obviously you weren't a
big fan of his and in a lot of ways
still aren't and I was not at all during
the primaries in a lot of ways I'm still
not I think we're seeing a transition
with President Trump that you've seen
with a lot of young conservatives who we
reach I think he was a guy who gave to
Democrats for most of his life who
really just he was doing business in New
York I don't really think it was a
dyed-in-the-wool Democrat either no I
think he was whatever he needed to get
his latest structure with his name
emblazoned across it erected um and I
think what you're seeing now though is
he's come in he thought the left would
play ball a little bit and they've been
so vicious which we've known them to be
they've attacked his family personally
we're not just ok screw you and he's
becoming more conservative I think we're
seeing a genuine transition of him
becoming more right-wing kind of like I
hate to say but venes are screwed later
in life everyone can kind of be redeemed
I think we're seeing with President
Trump I do think there's some of that
but how do we deal with the fact that
he's not you're not toxic in the same
way to young people so young people
watch your show because they know you're
a comedy guy right they're willing to
give you the benefit of the doubt when
you say something that's offensive
because as you say you know what's
offensive you know it's not and if
you're being offensive it's generally
being deliberately offensive right for
comedic purposes President Trump just
sort of says things yeah and he's sort
of in and he's very toxic for young
people I mean there's no question you
look at the polls and among young people
he's wildly unpopular how do you how do
we continue to maintain lines or draw
lines what do you think we are doing
here's one thing I was like he's
unpopular in a sense that a lot of your
fans and my fans probably aren't huge
Trump supporters that being said they do
like that someone has sort of thrown the
gloves off a little bit
so I think it's important to look at how
the question is
being framed you know kind of gonna say
oh and 90% of Americans are pro-abortion
but then when you give him a cutoff
where you show him a fetal chart they
got a fetal development chart that
changes right so I think with Donald
Trump if you were to ask me are you a
Donald Trump fan I'd probably answer no
but if you were to ask me do you think
that Donald Trump has done a relatively
good job as president I'd probably say
yes if you would ask me or prom I think
we would both agree on this culturally
definitely he's opened the door for
conservatives to not be so ashamed of
what they are even though he's not one
of them
but I don't think Marco Rubio would have
done this I don't think even senator Ted
Cruz I don't think chris Christie
obviously would have gone after the
media in the same way that Donald Trump
has so I think even though this thing is
squeaking is this being caught up on
here is it okay all right all right fine
I'm just making sure this I'm it's the
replication it's not me I just wanna
make sure you're okay - its no no no I'm
making sure that people know it's not me
it's my point then this is important for
me it's not everything is about you
there you go you can hear the squeak
it's the check so I think that's what's
important about President Donald Trump
even I think even though people may not
like him I think a lot of young people
are happy to see the burdens the
shackles of political correctness kind
of be thrown off and he has helped pave
the way for them so you live a very high
stress lifestyle obviously to your show
you're out in public a lot a lot of
people don't like it you said that
somebody put your drink on a plane so
that it's been a party for you how do
you how do you deal with the stress of
that I mean I've I have my own ways of
dealing with stress I go out and I kill
a puppy but what do you do well what do
you want to call your sponsor really
quickly what was that the life engine no
no no the help the second oh yeah yeah
no I do go see a psychologist that's
that's a real thing and I actually had a
some good friends where you'll see four
former UFC champions and I used to go
see a psychologist when I was and I
didn't get a lot out of it and the
psychologist I go and see is actually a
sports psychologist and executive
psychologist it's really more about time
management it's really more about okay
how are you being disciplined about your
rest you know I was talking with Dennis
Prager about this you kind of have to
fight against your nature and there is a
lot of comedians are lazy I'm not one of
those people I would border on paranoid
as far as we actually just printed out
just the jokes that we wrote less that I
wrote last year and not including the
research of the exhilarating pick it was
it was thousands upon thousands upon
thousands of pages just in jokes for the
show that's including the ones that made
it so it genuinely has helped me a lot
seeing the
kind of psychologist who's talked about
how to schedule your life and taught me
to be more disciplined about rest that's
not always feasible but I realized I was
running on you know four or five hours
of sleep every single night and they're
like okay you don't need to shoot for
eight or nine just shoot for seven
consistently shoot for a few five-minute
breaks where you can do some that's not
work-related because you know with what
we do and I'm incredibly grateful I'm
not complaining at all but with what
with what we do you're never finished
you just choose to stop right and
there's always one more thing that's
right and that is what's kind of
difficult about it like last night I was
getting back to the hotel I was taping a
pregger you video I don't think about in
the cat out of the bag it'll be out on
Columbus Day and some things went late
and I I was just going there's fifty
things I have to do but I'm just gonna
choose to stop that has been a big
revelation for me it's okay to choose to
stop at this point has your wife deal
with all that so you're married how long
married now six years okay so yeah a
kids ending in the foreseeable future
here you know it's funny you say that I
would love to be to point my life where
I could have kids and the things I've
always had to work so much recently so
that's one thing we're definitely
working on is finding more balance so we
are you know we don't have we don't have
the daily wire budget we're not exactly
running the Jim Henson budget that you
have here in your heat lamps but you
know getting you know getting sixteen I
would take a a 12-hour day most days you
know and maybe a ten-hour day here there
outside of Sunday and I think I'd have
more balanced life so it did they are in
the future just not right how does my
wife deal with all this I mean it's it's
it's hard it's hard yeah it is hard my
wife um she's very supportive you know
she did she worked she was a vice
president of a contract furniture
company she frogged some chairs that
don't squeak and she left the job and
she's just kind of she doesn't work for
me or the company full-time but she's
really good in her personally people
love her so for showing a guest around
or if we need to help kind of book some
travel she's been very helpful for her
that's been really relieving I think
this is with a lot of women you know
they think they think they have to work
their way up and she did she worked her
way up in a company but realize that's
not what you wanted to do it is hard on
her it's just like probably well your
wife is a doctor
obviously indeed yes so that's the rumor
and in a very a very attractive lady
your wife you've done very well for
yourself on and it with us
with what we do because like I said
especially my show is substantially at
more of a workload to put a Daily Show
like our a late-night show comedy shows
have to be written it yes and and we do
the sketches in the production you know
it's not really difficult so it's kind
of like we had Bryan Shaw World's
Strongest Man on the show recently we
had George daniel cormier current UFC
heavyweight light heavyweight champion
and it really is a partnership where
their wives have to support them in a
way that's not typical and weak I know
some women are gonna be furious when
they hear this but it is a volunteer
role but my wife is kind of accepted
that okay Steve's gonna need a little
more support because he isn't even that
if I don't help him with one she's not
gonna take 20 minutes to eat and that
comes down to you know when I'm done
working listening to her making sure
that her needs are met that's a really
important thing if we're gonna
about feminism then we need to talk
about being real men and that means yes
but I know it sounds namby-pamby ting
your wife's needs making sure that and
that's just that's not just physically
and financially we're talking about
spiritually emotionally making sure that
they feel heard that they feel safe um
so it really has been a learning process
and I will say that contra did some
people who we know my wife's are very
strong have you met my wife sure yeah
well yeah that's right am i with you
she's very stout on personality so for
us there was a lot of clashing early on
as opposed to some friends who were both
Type B personalities where they never
argued but some of these people just got
divorced like what happened
they never gone to marital counseling
they never had a fight and the first
fight was the blowout whereas my wife
and I the arc is it was a lot tougher
early on and it got easier do you think
we both got any better at marriage or
you just round off each other's edges a
little bit I think we both we've both
both now and listened to much DMX both
we've both gotten better at marriage and
communication for sure and and I think a
big a big part of it is is a you know
really learning that people inherently
are selfish you know men struggle with
pornography men always have for women
the pornography is romantic comedy and
The Bachelor right if he loves he'll
love me just the way I am no man loves
you just the way you are he loves you
just he loves you as you are but there
are things he doesn't like about you
just like you know a woman won't try to
change me woman is always gonna try to
change you I don't have a problem with
it means they're trying to better you
now if you become the only one that
you're working on if I'm working on me
and she's working on me and that's a
problem when we started our marriage
there was a lot of that I was the
project you know I needed a lot of work
and
now we've both both worked on ourselves
and and learned how to communicate more
effectively and I do think that is
something that's really important you
know in high pressure positions or high
profile positions people mocked mike
pence you know that's a good example a
lot of people don't understand for
example if you're alone in a car with a
woman who's not your wife
someone can snap a picture and it's a
big deal even if nothing happened this
is correct there are certain pressures
that come with your position my position
that a lot of people don't know this
isn't the celebrity relating yourself
from the possibility of sin is a
definite yes in any position where you
are prominent at all you've got to take
the proper precautions you've got to
determine what is a worthy risk and what
isn't I know this is what what's a
worthwhile risk for a guy who painted
menstrual blood I got the
irony is not lost but no my I wouldn't I
wouldn't have been able to accomplish
what we have you know what what moderate
success we have and I'm grateful for
with without my wife I have no doubt
about okay so I want to talk to you a
little bit about sort of your mental
state and well then we'll get into some
politics and social media and all the
first answer correct dude I mean you're
really catching on he's a quick learner
over here whether you're in a cafe or a
hotel we often rely on public Wi-Fi to
use the internet on the go but something
as simple as paying your bills online
from a Starbucks could leave your data
exposed a hacker could easily intercept
your information stealing passwords
credit card numbers or the pornography
that Stephen was browsing just before
the show it's not just hackers either
government agencies like the NSA they're
monitoring the entire internet they
could be scooping up your activity so
what can you do to defend yourself the
software I use to protect my online
activity from spies and data thieves is
expressvpn expressvpn has easy-to-use
apps they run seamlessly in the
background of my computer phone and
tablet expressvpn secures anonymizes
your internet browsing by encrypting
your data hiding that public IP address
using expressvpn I can safely surf on
that public Wi-Fi without being snooped
on having my personal data stolen
so check out expressvpn it cost less
than seven bucks a month and it comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee so
you got nothing to lose to take back
that Internet privacy today and find out
height and get three months for free go
to expressvpn comm slash Ben that's expr
ESS VPN comm slash man for three months
free with a one-year package again
expressvpn comm slash Ben to learn more
the hell are you doing on your iPad man
well I mean I'm decrypting all sorts of
national security
okay all right I think now we're using
word
I shot me I saw that I was not working
for now certainly not certainly not
doing now you're watching
interdimensional vampire that's correct
in any case let's talk about the fact
you're a crazy person so as everyone can
say you're a wild man and and this is
not a rip on you this is just the nature
partly of being in comedy that most
people who are in comedy I've never met
anybody who is a full-time comedian who
doesn't have edges right who who doesn't
have to be a wild man has to be on all
the time yeah so what do you think is
the relationship between comedy and
mental health between comedy and being a
wild person and having a normal life and
still having to be on all the time
trying to make people laugh gosh I don't
want this to become a Barbara Walters
where it becomes this interest that's
yourself real later yeah with a lisp and
a speech impediment we favorite tweet
how does she get that work does anyone
else know I mean who does she sleep with
Barbara Walters I mean not gonna go
really when she was young she was quite
the dish so it's not that gross you're
thinking of old Barbara Walters young
Barbara Walters had to bear with it with
the sitting u.s. senator from
Massachusetts that's right yeah but
that's not how she got the job so I do
wonder that she got the job you know I I
can't speak for all community but I
can't speak for myself I was I was
probably the kind of kid you hated in
school you were probably rajanya
throwing people in LA no no I actually
had no athletic ability whatsoever I was
a very late bloomer yeah well that I
didn't actually on my driver's license I
listed myself at 6 foot and you know
what no my senior year of high school I
was six foot one and a member competing
in judo at 144 pounds wool and I didn't
shave until I was like 2021 I just had
peach fuzz and I ain't get chest hair
until I was 24 the Crowder's are very
late bloomers and the potential for
being an angry late bloomer is scary and
I'm a relative there's a lot of velocity
now but I didn't pay attention at all
maybe a point you were just like there's
nothing there then all of a sudden yeah
it happened very very late um think
about when people this is one thing that
really bothers when we talk about mental
health and I've tried to be forthcoming
with a lot of people out there because
it seems the only time people talk about
it is when it's virtue signal you know
in Heath Ledger passes away it's like
everyone's uh I mean I just I've
struggled with this but where were you
when this didn't happen right you were
embarrassed to talk about it and so I've
talked with parents with their kids and
I say you know what's what's the advice
you would give to my kids and I've seen
them just react horrified by so don't go
to college if you don't know what you
want to do take some time figure it out
when people say were you ever suicidal
picture that
someone like myself son up at school
staring at a board in a way that I
couldn't possibly learn in a socialist
province for nine hours you try to want
to wake up the next day and it was like
I was I wasn't gonna David Carradine
myself was nothing like that
I just remember there were times in my
life in high school I just thought like
man I just I just wish I didn't have to
wake up tomorrow in the sense that I
just I hated my life so much it'd be
like me saying you have to coach
swimming starting tomorrow morning for
the rest of your life you know cause at
that point your life high school is
everything you know grade school high
school that's all you know so I'm not
big on men in speedos so yes these
arranger panties get it right our men
and art into armed services they deserve
our respect they deserve our respect
then that's the route for you now you
don't have any respect for anybody the
other difference is that I would know
that it was me in the end of that
sentence not U&I U&I
it says you and me you and I I have
respect for him and women our armed
services no-bid grammar is my space
ranger panties are yours irregardless
and allegedly let's go ahead I know you
said supposedly in alleged only
something only someone else who we know
we use the word irregardless we both
think is very smart that's where it was
you said supposedly allegedly which I'll
still argue is redundant because I don't
think that's but give me that one okay
there's someone we both know who we both
really respect as smart and he said like
you regardless four times yeah that's
that's it's not an accident when you're
sticking the landing like the fourth
time irregardless you're going okay man
you think that's a word so I really did
um I think a lot of the time but we see
as mental illness or mental affliction
is just people process things
differently because because once I went
to college my first semester before I
bombed out doing stand-up I was an A
student also because I was studying film
I was studying creative arts and I was
in my element
and I I did pretty well pretty quickly
in the areas where I was interested in
in the areas where I was interested see
I was just redundant there because I'm
trying to tread lightly here on the
issue of mental health so with myself I
think I just had to learn how I process
information and I had to get very
organized when people use us from ADHD
and by the way I'm totally against
obviously drugging up kids and putting
them on Ritalin
that being said I've actually done you
know not just a questionnaire but EEG
testing genetic testing we've done a lot
of your
that you're in the top percent it's not
even close like super super severe and
you know andrew breitbart obviously was
a prime example of that there are people
Winston Churchill would have been an
example of that a lot of people are now
you find just as many people by the way
with ADHD or these in the gutter as you
do great world leaders almost every
great world leader to some degree or
another was mentally afflicted whether
it was bipolar or a DD and I don't know
what you have I don't know what it is a
computer wore tennis shoes syndrome I
have no idea but so I think it's
important to talk about with people
because I think there are a lot of kids
out there who who think there's
something wrong with them and there's
there's really not there's a lot wrong
with our public education system today
there's a lot wrong with the way we
raise young men there's a lot wrong with
the way we discuss mental health of the
society but a lot of times there's
nothing wrong with these people
and I totally agree with a lot of that
and mental illness runs in my family as
well so I totally get where you're
coming from we actually didn't get the
full chronology of how you got from a
socialist province in Canada where you
wanted to kill yourself in a classroom
- you've living in Texas and making I
didn't want to kill myself I was hoping
I would like get hit by a car like I
would but I was actually hit by a car
once and I'm like no I gotta go back to
school the next day I'm gonna wait it
was it wasn't as good as you thought it
wasn't as good as I thought it would be
there's real letdown it was a left bound
by a rude french-canadian they're being
drivers have you been in Montreal yes
actually they will speed up to hit you
they're very rude the very skilled
drivers like in Europe but they're very
mean drivers so um yeah I was born in
Detroit which like it I've always said
he just an accent give to Canada really
and then raised in Montreal my mom was
french-canadian was born raised in
Quebec lived there from 3 to 18 and as
soon as I was able to you know get to
the States
I was doing some films and stand-up and
touring I did it immediately they have a
stand up for you because you still do
some standup but not as not nearly as
much ill happens time as much when we do
a show live show it's a full show you
have to bring in the whole team I just
did it recently had a yeah actually we
both did that weekend right you kind of
spoke and then I kind of do like 25
minutes of stand-up and then do it's
like a hybrid between that in keynote
I'm still feeling my way around with it
but yet stand-up starting off was um you
know I was just talking about this
yesterday with Dennis Prager
you know Stephen Harper was Canada's
Ronald Reagan yep and I remember being
at an overtime I met Stephen Harper I
asked him if he Barack Obama's president
asked him if
while he would invade but that's in any
case it wouldn't be a very long invasion
right he said if he asked me if he said
he said doesn't it make you a traitor I
said not if you win well so that makes
you a traitor
when you're here if you're rolling the
dice on that if you're gonna look at the
statistical likelihood you know it's
just a guy in a diesel playing with a
shotgun but so I remember an open mic
night when I was starting out doing CNF
it was when he had gotten elected and
all the comedians were bitching and
moaning about Stephen Harper getting
elected and now you have people like my
friend Mike Ward who back then I'm sure
would have been a liberal are now being
put before human rights Tribunal's for
speech for an unpopular jokes have you
had him on your show at all no not yet
no you know he his you know his joke was
his joke was and there's an in French so
I'm something might be lost in
translation there was like a kid who had
a make-a-wish in Canada was their
equivalent and his make-a-wish was to be
on Canadian Idol so here's the thing I
guess it turned out the kid wasn't as
terminally ill because he's still alive
and he was really bad he was a really
bad singer and so the guy this guy's bit
Mike Warwick saying you know everyone
was behind him and it was great but now
he just won't die that was his joke it's
a joke obviously
and he was put before human rights
tribunal Mike for $50,000 and lost and
now he's in an appeal so a lot of these
comedian I remember back then and
thinking you idiots do you understand
that there's only one political party in
this country - technically there's
because it's a parliamentary system but
the NDP is just super far left liberal
there's a liberal and NDP sarai we're
getting to the minutiae of Canada nobody
cares about the judges still wear funny
wigs sometimes but the point is I
remember they had a know they couldn't
realize it all like back then they
wouldn't be able to comprehend - Jordan
Peterson that this compulsion of
language
and I remember at that open mic night
going wow these people have no idea
what's coming they have no idea that
even if they're pro-abortion even if
they want to smoke weed the flip side of
the coin of Stephen Harper who also by
the way helped to prevent the housing
crisis in Canada who actually helped a
middle class do pretty well whereas here
they ended up footing the bill under
Barack Obama four years Canada actually
for the first time I think was hiring
the economic freedom index but the
freedom of speech it's not a
constitutionally enshrined right and for
me doing stand-up
earlier I just I I wasn't really super
political but I felt as though I had to
speak I felt as though I had to argue
with every single comedian
George Bush sucks and they would at that
plans like what John Kerry John Edwards
she have any idea the alternative in
places like Canada these people do want
they want to jail you for speech and I
felt like Chicken Little and no one was
listening but now people are
unfortunately and I think on for
unfortunately because this Trudeau guy
who's a national embarrassment if they
legalized Bernie
yes and some Bernie Sanders i handsome I
mean you know pretty would be the word I
would use I mean I bet you if you looked
at that man's free testosterone count it
would be non-existent and have you ever
seen his wife singing at the podium no I
will need only to show it to ya it's
it's a national embarrassment I get a so
viral on can of my french-canadian
family who don't speak English played
this for me when they were visiting but
um I do think that if he legalizes we'd
unfortunately he'll doesn't he'll win
again because of like oh there's weed
while people getting jailed for saying
you know offensive jokes and that scares
me so you went to college in the United
States or in Canada Canada okay and then
you and then you started doing stand-up
head you end up in the United States
why would let you in well I was born in
Detroit right yeah and I've talked about
this too big party eligible for the
presidency unlike Ted Cruz right yes
exactly exactly people would get that
wrong where the guy is ineligible but
you're not right is that something for
president running for president sounds
like a terrible job really watching
watching these people first of all the
quarters in the West Wing or when Trump
whined about like the state of the West
Wing you ever been in there it's really
they offered us a tour when we did the
change my mind and we didn't have time
yeah it's it's shockingly small like the
first time I heard Trump complain about
the West Wing I was like what a jackass
like complain about the West Wing meets
the people's house and then I'm like wow
this is like originally inhabited by
munchkins like by actual tiny Oh I'm not
I'm not a big human big and I was like
ducking to get through doorways in stuff
it's like going through one of the rooms
that's not that's not been remodel at
the Waldorf yeah this is terrible that's
exactly right it's like that scene from
Willy Wonka Chocolate Factory where they
start off at one end of the room and by
the time you get to the other end of the
room everybody sort of crouching down
and then Trump some big dude so I
imagine he actually has to Crisco
himself up you just wedge himself the
doorways to get around then at that
point the Crisco is incidental it's not
to wedge himself through the doorway
there's a multitude of uses and they get
so so sorry to get back to your store
you come to the United States you're
from Detroit how did you get back in I
was just I was just doing stand-up and
funny enough that you bring this up my
first man
was a guy named Tony Camacho who was
black in New York and the reason he
brought me on as a client was because I
ended my whole stand-up set on the
n-word I ended it and we're thank you
very much ladies gentleman and it was
actually a bit it wouldn't work now to
English but it was about French
Canadians who would rap and you would
actually hear French rap songs with
English cuss words including the n-word
and you would hear in the radio so be a
bunch of friend and then just n-bomb and
so it killed in Canada and he said man
it takes a lot of guts for a very white
guy like yourself to do that and I
really enjoyed the bit and he would not
be a conservative at all we used to but
he you know he he was a Christian guy
family values guy he was a conservative
who didn't realize it so he brought me
to the States and I just started doing
you know stand-up some some really
crappy clubs but got some pilots with
MTV and then got some films and
commercials and that took me full circle
so I was in LA and back in New York and
LA in New York again yeah it was it was
always just stand up and act and then
how'd you get out in like Fox News me
how do you go from stands up and acting
- yeah you know that story because you
know should I do my audience doesn't
yeah um how did did that start you know
what you were doing YouTube videos you
know what okay so that's this is this is
the part that a lot of people don't know
so there were no concerns on YouTube my
brother and I had done some YouTube
videos that had gone viral early on like
2006 there was a really bit I don't
remember there was a rash of bad
impression videos on YouTube early on
like 100 more impressions in three
minutes it's just some guy doing the
Family Guy cast in Kermit the Frog this
is terrible
so we did a YouTube video where was
called best impressions ever all caps
and it was me doing really bad
impression so my brother was my Ed
McMahon laughing and the reason it went
viral was because in the comments
section you had people who like this is
these are the worst impressions ever you
suck you know go kill yourself then you
had people saying this is satire you
don't get it go kill yourselves then you
had some people saying no actually these
are really good impressions you guys are
wrong and then you had some people who
just thought got the joke but didn't
think it was funny anyway so everyone
started fighting and we learned wow this
is how you make something go viral is
you get something that strikes a chord
but I didn't do anything politically
until I would say 2008-2009 and at that
point I just finished filming
doing a Christian film in San Diego and
I had done some episodes actually in an
ABC Family show where that was an
experience where I was actually talking
with a guy on set about South Park he
was talking about how much he liked it
and he said some things that made me
think he was conservative like in on the
gag but then I just realize he didn't
get the satire and he told on me to the
direct
rise like yeah I know I love the way
they Lampoon the left liberals means
like what are you talking about bro you
don't get it like no no like Trey and
Matt they were speaking at you like they
can't stand liberals and he was like no
man I don't think you know what you're
talking about
and as I supposed to have a multi series
arc the character I think which opposed
be named Jace and instead it was just
like drunken frat guy number two like in
two episodes so I learned very early on
so after this my parents said okay you
got you better have to get a job and I
never I never had had to work a job
before if I was going back to stay home
and real I was going back to stay home
because I was burnt out and I said okay
how about this I'm going to for the next
six months treat YouTube like a
full-time job I'm gonna upload a video
every week just put up a blue bedsheet
in the wall and I actually messaged
people every single day for six hours a
day saying hey might want to check out
my channel and responding and that's why
I got the first 10,000 subscribers the
first semi viral video was crazy Pete's
abortion barn right that's one I
actually read from the Planned
Parenthood website because they sounded
like a used car salesman and that was
when I learned early on if I just
actually read Planned Parenthood's
transcript effectively it doesn't matter
how offensive I am as a used car
salesman selling abortions at half price
and then the quran challenge and things
sort of became viral and then Andrew I
had heard Andrew Breitbart on the Dennis
Miller show and just called him and you
know Henry spoke with me for 30 minutes
so he put up some of my old stand-up and
people liked it so I started writing
articles PJTV came along and I started
working with them and then Fox News when
I was working here at PJ chibi in Los
Angeles they said hey do you want to
come appear on our on our network and I
said sure I didn't know by the way but
we can talk about it now but I didn't
know about the rivalry between O'Reilly
and Hannity so Hannity called and I said
yes and then the O'Reilly people called
right afterward and I said yes and then
they called back and said well hold on a
second we didn't know you were doing
Hannity have to pick one we're the
bigger show I said well I gave him my
word and then I was persona non grata
yeah we all those of us who work in the
industry I remember the world's biggest
heist it was so terrible so um what
happened was I think they brought me in
to lose because I was on a debate when
they first brought me in and I think it
surprised a lot of people that I did
relatively well I think they weren't
used to sort of someone who was a little
bit quicker as a comedian it's kind of
just like fighting someone who's
unorthodox and then they brought me back
and brought me back and then when I
started appearing on other news networks
they didn't really know what they wanted
to do with me they just knew they didn't
want anyone else
to have me so that's what they were
paying for back then was exclusivity and
it was four and a half years in my life
I'm very grateful for the experience but
I'm very grateful now to be doing what I
what I want to be doing and did not have
the muzzle on well I'm definitely gonna
ask you about some of where your
political perspective was formed and
also you know the areas of your career
we've gone serious mainly the they
changed my mind stuff so I'm gonna ask
about all that in just one second first
let's talk about change because this
dude right here doesn't have any pants
but he could use some pants because come
the hell on it's just terrible in every
possible way if you are looking for
quality jeans that look great fit great
feel great and used to cost you hundreds
of bucks Matan bow has permanently
changed the game with $200 designer
jeans for half the price introducing
Mountain bow calm or you can get the
most comfortable premium jeans you will
ever ever wear for half of what you
would pay elsewhere for a G or seven
jeans I mean these are luxury jeans for
a hundred bucks you can only get them at
Matt and Bo com I wear jeans every day
motton bow is fantastic most comfortable
because they use the best in comfort
technology that got dynamic stretch
premium because the only source their
denim from two of the most well
respected denim mills on planet earth to
make sure that your jeans fit you
perfectly they have an at-home Tryon
program as well you request a second
pair with your order you try on both you
keep one you send back the other one in
the same box with the prepaid label
these are $200 designer jeans for half
the price plus their September savings
event means that you save 20% on
everything and Matt and Bo comm / Ben
that's M ot T and Bo w.com / Ben for 20%
off everything this is their best deal
anywhere it is only available for the
month of September so now is the time to
do it save 20% during mot in both
September savings events at Matt and Bo
comm / Ben again that's Matt and Bo comm
/ Ben don't get caught without pants
like this gentleman who's sending me
right here infinities horrifying
everyone with his manly legs instead go
check out Matt and Bo comm slash men
save 20% during their September savings
event okay sounds like a good deal
actually it's very hard for me to get
jeans because I have a pretty small
waist but a huge ass so it's gonna
mention either they their pants my waist
is 33 but after about like 36 or 38
pants because they're made for men
without legs well I mean which as you
can clearly see is not a problem
Wow you know if if I like and I should
have put a ring on it I said yeah who
says I'm not wearing a second ring let's
continue with your question on my
worldview good
Wow Wow so let's talk about where your
values came from those solid family
values that we are on discussing right
here so you grew up in Canada which is
socialist America where connect
specifically Quebec so where where did
your conservative values come from so I
was always you know as a Christian
family now you but you're never just
born a Christian you have to decide at
some point just I would assume is
probably this I mean you're culturally
Jewish or your ethnic gotta buy an in a
certain plane you're gonna buy out
exactly yeah some point either say this
is what I believe or not and the same
thing with with being a Christian so I
was raised in a Christian household
though and then I started working really
young and so my dad told me about taxes
it was it was really that simple and I
found that almost everyone I really
liked or enjoyed later on in life I
found was a conservative like John
Stossel
I used to wait for his give me a break
segments laughs after TGIF in 2020 like
he where he would just just take a
steaming one he just drop it all over
something like New York liberals and I
even know what a liberal or conservative
was a kid please give me a break you
know he talked to this head of Navajo
Nation the white man forced me to live
this way and he said but you're wearing
jeans and as a kid I was like I want to
be this guy now if I could merge him and
David Letterman so I inherited all ways
kind of an individualist and I had a
just like Woody Allen I had a general
problem with authority so I think that
just sort of culminated in what you see
before you
bogel before you how did you decide to
your show is really split in an
interesting way so mine is based on
serious material and then I'll stray
every so often and make joke or do a
weird impression that's usually pretty
bad but for you because they shade that
first part of getting help is admitting
you have a problem they're not all that
bad they're not all that they're not all
that bad Trump sucks my Obama is okay
okay they're not all that bad okay being
imitated your faces so it's active think
that's actually the imitations of you
are really actually not very insulting
no there's not like chanc Weger which
you saw when I actually invaded shanks
panel as I think it's like you're like I
don't I don't know which one to shoot
because like we fight a man named Lana
but her both the same there was a point
in never actually sat down and he was
going okay okay and his own audience
started laughing at him but the stuff he
was you just yo you look young in a
bitter woman
and sound and you speak quickly yeah so
sorry your question so the question was
how do you when do you decide to stray
into serious territory so the change
your mind stuff has become
extraordinarily me mobile so we've all
seen the memes various be our own
company has taken me put me behind that
desk of you that picture of you behind
the desk with your feet up with it with
the change my mind about some weird
thing that's a PewDiePie has made fun of
it like legitimately everybody has made
fun of it
how did you where did you come up with
that idea number one and number two
that's a pretty serious segment there's
there's not a ton of humor in that when
did you decide that you were gonna do
kind of more serious material along
those lines well I you know humans owned
by others have been hated by others but
never do yes yes I know I know exactly
what you're talking about um it's always
been a mix you know that was one thing I
hate you know I feel I don't want to be
put in a box because the truth is people
come to the show to laugh to be
entertained but people also really enjoy
I mean our rule on our show is I tell
people if you're if we are creating
content or if I create content that does
not meet this criteria cut it tell me to
cut it it either has to be well first up
it always has to be entertaining and it
either has to be informative or
enlightening and informative means you
know we're breaking news like with the
people who wanted to stab supporters at
the University of Utah remember that
call until I'm like hey listen they
handed out a knife to us and handing out
you're like they're they're handing out
ice picks yes Ben you're security can
like what do you have like here's the
footage they're like oh my god and that
guy from Nightline was following you no
interest in the story at all there's a
knife and ice picks we have a deal with
the FBI so it's always been a mix I
actually think our show has led to more
arrests or charges than any other
conservative program accidentally
because of the research that we've done
we've just kind of fallen into because
we stay in character
um so change my mind though you know
what's funny that's basically I was
turned down by every major conservative
publisher I think there might be one or
two out there who didn't when I pitched
a book and back then it wasn't called
changed my mind but it's what it's what
has become changed my mind and they
remember them the words actually being
spoken conservatives don't by comedy
they don't by funny books they by Obama
doomsday books at this point I think at
that point the book Obama the Obama
blueprint was like really big so that's
what people really wanted to do and it
just wasn't what I wanted to do is I
don't know there's anything wrong with
the book I'm an insulting the book it
just wasn't changed my mind and so if
one thing to you know you're very sharp
you're very very smart and it's it's
formidable for people to watch you in a
debate but I know that a lot of people
can watch you or even sometimes myself
I've had people say why I can't do that
no on a second actually yeah you can
particularly when it comes to a
conversation with somebody whose mind
can be changed almost people who are
left don't they they haven't yet
rationalized their positions now it is
also very different when you have a
microphone and a stage and I do or we're
on cable news it's a different dynamic
and we're always saying then I just wish
that we could sort of capture these
conversations that we have with people
you know when I get whether I'm getting
my hair cut or I'm in an uber I'll have
these conversations with people and it'd
be completely unedited so that people
could see it's not that hard to do that
almost anyone can do it you don't have
to win an argument you just have to know
how to rationalize your position that's
really what it stemmed from and it just
happened to strike a chord it's the
exact opposite of everything we've been
taught in media and I know in podcasting
though there's this pride in like we
don't have any kind of prep or show map
or anything and they just but then
they've gone for our rabbit trails you
know about duck genitalia or whatever
the hell it is we pick a topic and we
stick to the topic we make sure the
people rationalize their positions so
there is a direction with it it's not
completely random and haphazard but it's
it's very genuine and I think that a lot
of people just appreciated I was
antithetical to what we've no media I
couldn't tell you exactly why it's
worked as well as it has honestly that's
my hypothesis so you know I think both
you and I have been into space where
we've both been very irritated by the
sort of star genus of conservative media
by the fact that so much of conservative
media seems stuck in a rut unwilling to
kind of move out of that right what do
you think that rut is how do we define
it how do how do you break out of it how
do you think that the conservative
movement can move past its images stodgy
because I mean you know me I'm better
stodgy human being as it's possible to
be I listen to classical music I go to
synagogue on a regular basis I go home
my wife would you synagogue
apparently I mean I mean when we're not
planning world domination there's pretty
stodg if you're in last name weren't
Shapiro that would sound incredibly
anti-semitic what then I would just say
synagogue is so stodgy I hate those
synagogue attendees well I mean I don't
mean you go there for parties but it's
like the raves going on at the synagogue
it's not just a bunch of glow sticks on
a rabbi but by the same token obviously
the conservative movement has it feels
yes er stodgy or
provocateur ish those are the only two
yeah
those are the only two medium in which
people tend media in which people tend
to work right you've got like the malian
A+ I'm just gonna say stuff to say stuff
and piss people off yeah and then you've
got the Paul Ryan let me walk you to
death right how does conservatism find a
middle ground that actually appeals to a
broader swath of people well first off I
know that you really hate those sort of
The provocateur ship if that's the word
just for the sake of it and I appreciate
that you've delineate between what we do
and people who just go out there and say
something
you know racist I appreciate that
because I don't listen we could get in
hot water and I know that you know our
heart and where we come from and our
goal is never to actually just to
denigrate people or even even
necessarily I did know some of them like
Bernie Sanders that's fine but yeah you
know it's it's here's a solution what
you're doing and what I'm doing and I
think it'll actually the closing segment
on this week's show this Thursday if we
see people all the time say won't
somebody do something I mean how many
rooms did we sit in with these
underground organizations I think the
cats out of the bag with that one we're
like where's a conservative late-night
you know where's the answer to The Daily
Show and I was at Fox pitching the show
that I'm doing for day in and out for
four and a half years and I'm just
saying no it's not gonna work
they paired me up with a guy who was
like he was like 90 years old with four
year old kids like that's Old Testament
Abraham but I don't know I'm so bizarre
and he like had these ideas like a
monkey on rollerskates and what it is is
just people and this is true I know I'm
trying to remember together my time
there people say well what isn't some
why don't we have this isn't someone
going to do something just be the guy
who does something we're doing the show
that we wish we wished had existed
people told me there was no market for
it I'm very grateful for the market that
there there is for it and every time we
gain a new subscriber a new mug club
member we've raised the ceiling and we
really are just incredibly grateful I
think there are two ways to handle
success to either become to either exalt
yourself or to feel genuinely humbled by
the responsibility of how much it means
to people and and that's honestly I like
when I got off stage at SMU I remember
walking in the bathroom in like like
crying a little because for me as a kid
stand-up that was kind of a dream come
true to have you know 2,700 people
roaring and cheering like for someone
else that didn't mean a whole lot but
for me that was something that I thought
about ever since I was a kid and you go
oh what do i do from from here you know
how do i hang onto this and this also
and some of these people were crying
because you know they left the
left Islam and now they couldn't talk
with their parents or giving me their
Navy Cross so I it's just be the person
who does something we're doing the show
that we wanted to do and I know that you
for a long time listen you did a lot of
AM radio and you you appeared on a lot
of a stool I didn't yes in a lot in a
lot of trench but you finally just I
know that you're going why doesn't
somebody do some I know behind closed
doors sometimes people who are more
high-profile respectful you think
they're idiots
and I know that you're like man I'm ten
times smarter than that guy yeah you you
you are but this is just the way the
system works right now and now you're
doing it and now we're doing it so I
just think for people how does it change
it changes with what we're doing and
hopefully more people out there doing it
I you know I don't see many been
Shapiro's in the horizon there are a lot
of people who are young and smart
they're there's no one else out there as
far as young comedians that's what kind
of worries me for me to retire I would
love to pass that torch to somebody
there's just it's gonna be ten years
before sort of someone's come as hell to
get out 31 but I can't I can't do this
for that long
oh really okay so how long do you think
here I would love I would love to be
able to train someone up you know within
10 years and have someone else be doing
the tired 41 now retired but be able to
you know be able to help the next
youngest what's your tournament so
lately you just decide not to do this as
often or you do it occasion well yeah
well again because I was pitching this
showed it like I'm sure you probably
pitched books that got turned down well
you all you're getting published at what
seven years old and nineteen but yeah
okay yeah but you didn't look a day past
fourteen so it was that see that's what
really counts but um I would love to be
the person who said to a young steven
crowder this will never work
change my not mind is not a book that
people want late-night comedy is not
something that conservatives want I
would love to be the guy goes okay kid
you're you're talented let's see how
hard you work at it and let me you know
be it be a wind in your sails here I'd
love to be able to do that eventually
you know it's it's really not about
myself because if it dies with me then
it's all for for nothing unfortunately
there aren't many conservative I don't
even say comedians but entertainers out
there you know because the system kind
of like you said it breeds sort of young
CNN crossfire air at Tucker Carlson
look-alikes when you go to a lot of
these conventions and that's changing
now that's changing a lot you're seeing
a very you're seeing a much more diverse
group of people like when I went to
speak it yeah you're seeing a lot of
alternative
well you know people there with tattoos
and Mohawks are seen a lot of people who
are not afraid to at least to at least
explore their options so that's what's
important to mean I would really love to
see some more people coming up notes
they've got to earn it
I think this is right I mean there's a
cultivated skill set and I've seen it
even with you because I've known you
long enough me I've known you for a
decade so I've seen how even in the time
we've known each other your comedy has
really progressed to the point where I
mean you were always good but now you're
just terrific in a way that you weren't
a long time ago and that is through
cultivation of skill and effort and I
feel the same way about my own career
and I've been doing this since I was 17
which means I've been doing this for 17
years now and I feel like I've gotten
better at it because you put in the time
and you get better you've got in so many
reps in yeah exactly exactly like at a
certain point you you really have to
cultivate a skill it feels like the
movement spends an awful lot of time
promoting people who have not actually
spent the time cultivating the skill
yeah if you if you either mouthed the
platitudes or alternatively if you troll
when these are these are the two paths
to fame and glory in the conservative
movement which as you say a bumper
sticker or you say something really
truly just to get attention right and
then you are celebrated by the people
who are glad that somebody said
something offensive right that's not I
think where the future is amendment lies
that's where I'm inspired to see you do
so well because there was a period like
you and I both know there was a period
not that long ago where we thought our
careers were in doubt because it was
just the whole kind of trolli or bumper
sticker slogan we both I remember
talking a new phone oh yeah these
conversations like man I don't know if
this is the end of this where it's it's
a bumper sticker or just saying
something outlandish but that's not what
we do and we're not gonna change who we
are so you know your success I always I
always sort of that if I seriously lived
through your success from like man that
I'm glad to see that someone can do what
Ben does because he's doing what he
wanted to for a long time it is more
substantive it is not what media used to
be and guess what people have been
craving it that means a lot to me
one of my one of my favorite films like
we talked about we're talking about
passing the torch he was he the Shootist
was John Wayne's last film yep okay so
if we who don't know it's about you know
sky who'd wants to live out his last day
I think he has cancer or pancreatic
cancer it was it's a young Ron Howard
and is it's a Gregory Peck and their
whose or is it Jimmy Stewart knows Jimmy
Stewart and who's a woman is it a net I
can't remember I don't know anyway but
the point is he goes to this town he's
this famous Shootist you know he's a
shootout artist and he wants
he wants to live quietly but
unfortunately a young Ron Howard lets
the word out that this guy is in town
and everyone wants to take their crack
at him and at this point John Wayne has
a death wish
he wants to die so at that point he goes
out publicly to the saloon and he can
see all of the guys there who are ready
to shoot him and it's a very powerful
scene for me because it's the end of the
movie the end of the film and um there's
a shootout and at a certain point
actually he shot everybody but there's I
think one guy left with a shotgun
trained on him and he pauses because he
knows he could let this happen and he
wants to die but instead he turns out
and shoots the guy and finishes his
drink and he's it's kind of melancholic
and it's because he wanted to be taken
out but he wasn't gonna give it to me
and that's kind of how I want there to
be someone else eventually but it's got
to be someone who same thing I'm sure
with you as you get older when you were
tight it's got to be someone who you can
entrust with what we've built and I
think also it's a big space and I hope
there are a lot of voices in it so I say
I hope that you're wrong and that you're
continuing to do this after you know
after the age of 41 because come on but
I just don't want to have to but okay so
you have one more question for you I
wanna hear your greatest fear for the
country and your greatest hope for the
country but for our listeners if you
actually want to hear Stephens answer
you have to be a daily wire subscriber
to subscribe go to daily wire comm click
subscribe and you hear the end of our
conversation over there well man who
certainly is not a coward in the hosts
of lateral Carter Steven thanks so much
for stopping by dude it's great to see
you thank you sir hand on the leg hey no
no I'm kidding I won't okay
[Music]
the venture Pierrot shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex singhara audio is
mixed by Mike Carroll Mina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah all vera and title
graphics by Cynthia and Gullu the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright for publishing 2018
[Music]